2022 saw plenty of strong exclusives
from the Nintendo switch including
multiple Pokemon games and new games
featuring the likes of both Kirby and
Bayonetta however 2023 is the year many
have been looking forward to including
myself thanks to a little game called
The Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
so with that here are the biggest
Nintendo switch games coming out in 2023
and Beyond
I'm starting this list off with a bang
Hollow Knight silk song yes it's
releasing multi-platform and yes one of
those platforms is the Nintendo switch
Hollow Knight for those who didn't play
it is in my humble opinion one of the
greatest metroidvania games of all time
silk song was initially going to be a
DLC expansion to hollow Knights and it
grew so big that it became its own game
in silk song players will take control
of hornet an unplayable character from
the first game Who regularly interacts
with and battles the night Hornet has a
unique moveset compared to the Knight
such as a diagonal downward strike and
slightly different system for healing
which creates a different feel even if
the games are similar from what little I
played at E3 2019 the game absolutely
held up to the original and honestly
this may be my personal most anticipated
game even over Zelda silksang is set to
release June 12 2023
Pikmin 4 has had a lengthy development
cycle to say the least back in 2015
Shigeru Miyamoto teased that it was in
development and since then the only
updates have been that it was low
priority and slowly progressing however
Pikmin fans finally saw an exciting
update in 2022 that Pikmin 4 was on its
way in 2023 10 years after the release
of Pikmin 3. not much is known from the
very brief teaser not even if you'll
play as Olimar Louis or someone
completely new however I'm sure cute
Pikmin goodness and fun Garden themed
puzzles are on their way
speaking personally here Advanced Wars
is one of my favorite grid-based
strategy games so it was both exciting
when a remake was announced for 2021 and
a shame when the game was delayed to
2022 and then indefinitely delayed due
to the war in Ukraine for those who
haven't played Advanced Wars the game is
a super simple turn-based grid strategy
game similar in many ways to Fire Emblem
however instead of leveling up specific
units you'll be capturing bases and
using finances to purchase them with
each Commander you can control having
specific abilities that can turn the
ties of battle while the gameplay is
deceptively simple it's one of those
perfect strategy games where it's easy
to learn but takes time and skill to
master hopefully we'll see a 2023
release of the reboot
speaking of fantastic grid-based
strategy games a brand new Fire Emblem
Fire Emblem engage is on its way to the
Nintendo switch Fire Emblem was nearly
on its way out before Fire Emblem
Awakening and breathed new life into the
series on the Nintendo 3DS then in 2019
Fire Emblem saw the excellent Fire
Emblem 3 houses which went on to become
the best-selling Fire Emblem game in the
franchise Fire Emblem engage has its own
interesting concept and the player being
able to utilize Fire Emblem Heroes of
the past to help them fight including
the likes of Marth and one of the
greatest Fire Emblem characters of all
time lindis at the very least making an
appearance Fire Emblem 7 is the best
Fire Emblem fight me Fire Emblem engage
is set to release January 20 2023
while we're here in turn-based Grid
strategy land it seems like 2023 will be
a great year for fans of this style of
game Metal Slug tactics which was
initially set to be released in 2022 was
delayed and now set to release in 2023
snk's Metal Slug games were known for
their fantastic and fun artwork as well
as brutal difficulty they were arcade
coin-eating beat em up games that were a
whole ton of fun and Metal Slug tactics
seems to capture that same artistic
energy but in the tactics genre that
said it's unclear if the game will
maintain the brutal difficulty of their
predecessors however if you want a brand
new Tactical experience this is
definitely something worth keeping an
eye out for Metal Slug tactics has no
set release date but currently is
supposed to release sometime in 2023
if there's one game series that didn't
see enough spin-offs or sequels it was
Jet Set Radio the Fantastic Dreamcast
game spawned one single sequel just at
Radio Future before the series sadly
hung up its futuristic rollerblades
however the year is 2023 and a spiritual
successor from Team reptile by the name
of bomb Rush cyberfunk is on its way how
much of a spiritual successor is it well
not only does it look visually in
gameplay wise incredibly similar to Jet
Set Radio games but the team even
managed to secure a number of tracks
from Legendary game composer Hideki
naganuma naganuma wrote the incredibly
funky and fresh song ain't nothing like
a funky beat for the team's former game
lethal League Blaze and is back at it
with another hot track in get enough for
bomb rush cyberfunk so get ready to
grind your way through the dopest Game
of the Year in summer 2023
octopath traveler released exclusively
on the switch back in 2018 before
eventually coming to PC and Xbox One
it's gorgeous HD 2D Graphics have since
become a new staple of Square Enix and
were utilized in games like live a Liv's
remake and triangle strategy it also has
an absolutely beautiful soundtrack
octopath traveler 2 features a brand new
world from the first game with 8 new
characters and 8 new stories I'm
personally hoping they intertwine a
little more than the first game but any
RPG fan should be overjoyed to see a new
octopath coming out octopath traveler is
set to release February 24 2023
in pepper grinder you'll take control of
pepper a drill wielding treasure hunter
who's been Shipwrecked and robbed the
gameplay has you drilling through the
environment at quick speeds collecting
treasure and solving puzzles you'll be
able to use these Treasures to upgrade
pepper and your drill the game looks to
be a fun fast-paced game with a great
system of movement and it's one that I'm
personally looking forward to pepper
grinder releases sometime in 2023
if games like unravel or It Takes Two or
up your alley you just may be into Blanc
an upcoming Co-op Adventure game where
players control either a wolf cub or
Fawn who have been stranded in a
snowstorm the two players will have to
work together to navigate through
obstacles in this absolutely adorable
animal Adventure block releases February
14 2023 just in time for Valentine's Day
just saying
all right so admittedly this one may not
be coming out in 2023 but we can all
hope way back in 2017 it was announced
that Metroid Prime 4 was in development
and since then there have only been
minor updates with it being revealed in
2019 that developments had restarted
under Retro Studios this same Studio
behind the original Metroid Prime while
Metroid fans got to scratch that 2D
exploration itch with Metroid dread in
2021 the Prime series is its own
wonderful and unique thing and the last
game we saw was released way back in
2007 so here's to hoping that 2023 is
the year of Metroid Prime 4.
as I alluded to in the intro The Legend
of Zelda tears of the kingdom is the
hotly anticipated sequel to breath of
the wild since the release of breath of
the wild the game has become such a
beloved game in Mainstay it's difficult
to find open world games that haven't at
least been somewhat influenced by it or
at the very least compared to it fairly
or not while the breath of the wild
sequel was teased to come out far sooner
as breath of the wild release in 2017
and tears of the kingdom is using the
same engine to our understanding six
years later we're finally seeing tears
of the kingdom come to fruition and it's
those six years that makes tears of the
Kingdom stand out even more Zelda games
are known for their high quality and the
fact that the team takes how much time
it seems to need to create some of
Gaming's most stunning and memorable
games whether it completely reinvents
the wheel with a breath of the wild or
iterates in fantastic ways a la Majora's
Mask so here's the hoping tears of the
kingdom is the Majora's Mask the breath
of the wild a game that takes the
foundation of breath of the wild but
iterates in fantastic new ways I know
this sounds overwhelmingly positive for
a game that hasn't been released yet but
Nintendo rarely lets this Zelda fan Down
The Legend of Zelda tears of the kingdom
is set to release May 12 2023.
and there you have just some of the best
switch games coming out in 2023 was
there anything we missed let us know in
the comments and I'll see you next time